hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar humoral
response after sars kobe 2
mrna vaccine in a cohort of hemodialysis
patients
and kidney transplant recipients i am
michelle
ashton of labbers and i'll be your
moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinth
brought to you by diathorn we encourage
you to participate today
by submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
at the end of the presentation you may
also
submit any technical issues here as well
if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation i'd like to
now welcome our speaker
professor sebastian hunts senior medical
virologist
and a university hospital of limouse
france
head of the department of infectious
serologies
deputy director of the national
reference center
for herpes viruses professor hans you
may now begin
your presentation
thank you very much for the invitation
to speak about our work uh
that we though that we did in
our university hospital in emerge france
about the humeral resistance uh after
uh
in a court of hemodialysis patient and
kidney transplant recipient
to summarize some points about
the curving 19 uh pandemic
just a few few days ago
there was more than 170 milli
millions people
infected over the world and more than
3 million doses of vaccine
uh three million of uh
deaths over the world so this pandemic
was very uh was an
urgent need to to come
to fight and uh these data
are available from the who
w h o sorry um
[Music]
site website
some word about the virus the task of
two
to better understand the different essay
that we will use after and
to better understand why all the essays
are not equivalent
so the virus that everybody well known
today is composed from
an arena it is
the genome and this arena is
protected with the nucleocapsid thanks
to protein
n and the virus is an enveloped
virus in this envelope the protein spike
is responsible from the attachment
of the virus to the
to the cell
at the under on the right part
of the slide you can
see the three-dimensional structure
of the spike protein in the pre
the conformation where you
can see the different essential domains
that are represented
in the figure a
in green you can see the herbid the
receptor binding domain
that allowed the virus to
attach the ete receptor
on the surface of the cells
and after the attachment the virus can
entry into the into the set
other domain of the spy protein
are essential you can see the n-terminal
domain in blue
and the domain s1 and s2
and we will talk after of these
different domains
for the for the numeral response
against the spike protein
after the infection of the virus
you can use different
assay in a laboratory diagnosis to
detect the virus
or to detect the response the humor
the immune response to the virus
so in this figure
published last year
you can observe that
the virus begins to be
detected some by pcr
very very early in the infection
and uh
just the uh
just before the the week before this is
the first symptoms
the virus can already be detected by
pcr and the detection
the this sorry this
say is the that that was this assay
was chosen uh to
investigate a copy 19 infection
in the over the world from the beginning
of the pandemic
this early detection explained
what some people could be
transmitted could transmit the virus
to other people
without symptoms
after the onset of symptoms
the better is always positive
and you can observe in this
figure that the human response
begins to appear
after the first week at the beginning
you have you are
you have some idm antibodies and
then appears igg and after
two weeks in general you have
antibodies in almost
all people and then
the replication of virus decreases
and the pcr begins to
begin beginning to
become
at the same time antibody detection
could
continue to be a method
to detect past infections
to complete this data on
humeral response post infection
in this excellent
work uh published in nature medicine
last year
uh the households showed that
median time to zero conversion
was e 13.
as you can see on the figure
with the depending from the time
you can see that the there is an
increasing level
of igm
in blue and an increasingly
level of agg
after three weeks in general
you can observe that the
level of idm begin to decrease
when we compare severe and non-civil
form
clinical form of kobi90
you can often observe that
igg titus is more important
what are sorry idg tutors are more
important
if the form is cv
and an important uh
point that we observed during this
funding one more than one year after the
beginning is that the is that
the antibodies
anti-nuclear capsid decrease
more rapidly than
that antibody against
anti-spike protein so
when you when you are
some months after
infection you can
sometimes not detect
on tn antibodies but continue to detect
on ts and in the last
publications uh it
was written that
on the sidg can be detected until
12 months after infection
and these antibodies are correlated with
protection because
the risk of infection decreased by
nearly 100 percent
so against this new infection
there was only until now
only one means when mean
the vaccination or
it is very interesting to look
at the number of backsides in clinical
development
at the 8th of june
so three two
two days ago the one more than
on 100 vaccine clinical development
and almost 200 back signs
in pre-clinical development so it's very
enthusiastic to to see that
a uh number of researchers of
manufacturer have
developed developed have developed
vaccine
or tried to develop backside
so uh in this
this research actually
we have full vaccines
available in france uh
the vaccine from pfizer the community
or bnt 162 b2
the vaccine of moderna mrna one 1273
the vaccine of astrazeneca bacteria and
the vaccine of jensen
commandment in vaccine genes
i show the name of the vaccine in
different cycle
and the cycle
are
proportional the size of the cycle are
proportional to the number of vaccine
available on
on our territory
numbers
a lot of studies have been
performed to
[Music]
to explore the immunogenicity
of the vaccines and then the
efficacy of this website
but when we
read with attention all the paper
there is a lot there is a different
k exclusion criteria in these studies
and among these criteria
you have no infection with hiv
hepatitis c virus or repetitive virus
but
what is
more important for our concern is
that no people with immunocompromised
condition
or history of autoimmune disease
know of such people have been included
in these two days and naturally
no people with previous clinical or
microbiology
the other diagnosis of copyright
it's logic so
first we will
look at the results of immunogenicity of
the most used vaccine in france
the vaccine from pfizer and the vaccine
from
terna and
concerning the immunogenicity in healthy
people
the first publication of welsh in the
new england journal of medicine
last october showed that
concerning on ts-1 antibodies prediction
the response
is different depending on
the age of participants and
naturally depending on the number of
studies
in this protocol
the prediction
was done with 10 microgram
to 30 microgram of bnt 162b2
and you can see on the figure
that the response
is very similar
whatever the quantity of antigen
administrated
but what is more interesting
is that uh the
second loser here three week
after the first
enhance the response it's a real boost
as you can see and uh
interestingly the best presents
where were obtained with 20
micrograms as you can see here
whereas 30 micrograms are not
the best do this
so this
first result of immunogenicity are very
interesting and
[Music]
when you compare the results of
holder participants
you can see that the response
is really lower
because the scale is logarithmic
so even if
the size of isogram seems
similar the difference is
very important
with response around
ten thousand four young people
and three thousand to
eight thousand with
30 microgram in older people
in healthy people
because no immunocompromised
patients were included in these studies
uh it's interesting to
look at the neutral neutralizing
response
uh the essay was done uh with the task
of do
the reservation test and
we evaluate the fifty percent in library
uh we don't with a fifty percent in the
variation
uh so the
like for the evaluation of rcsr response
we can see that there is a
important difference between
young and older people
because the runs
vary from 1.7 to 4.6 times
the giantee of the correlation serum
panel among participants
among young participants and 1.1 to
2.2 times the giant of the comparison
panel among older people
so these
first results show that
the difference between
both populations is
induced by the decrease of efficacy
of immune response with agent
so when we will
look at the response of
immunocompromised patients
which are who are often uh
older than healthy people
you you can imagine that you combinate
two factors of lower resonance
another result of immunogenicity in
healthy people
with the vaccine of moderna
to see that the response
are very similar between both backside
in healthy people
the
zero conversion was uh analyzed
in uh was observed sorry
in all participants by the
uh
at day 43 multi virus neutralizing
activity
capable of reducing task of doing
infectivity by
80 percent of more or more detected in
all participants
with with gmt
response to more than 300
in the 25 microgram group
and more than fifo 600
in the 100 microgram group
more recent study shows
uh the studio of anderson published in
new england journal
showed that mrna
one vaccine from modern art
induces specific igg reference
and neutralizing antibodies
in adults older than
70 years of a so
it's interesting but the
difference was similar between
older and new population
like with either backside
some publication of describes
the response
after vaccination in immunocompromised
patients
and what the household said
is that vaccines tend to be
most effective early in the course of
renal disease
so you have to vaccine as soon as
possible
response often weaker than
immunocompetent patients
and that's why they gave recommendation
for vaccinations
early after diagnosis of renal disease
or if possible before graft
this recent recommendation were
published
this year and
another publication an older publication
but says also
interesting point that the types and
doses of immunosuppressive agents
administered may have an effect on
backside immunogenicity
to these have found that mycophenolation
was
associated with decreased zero response
to influenza vaccine
in kidney transplant reception in a dose
dependent session
so we will talk again
about this point in houston
so why we are interested
with patients with our patients is that
there is no efficacy that's available
immunocompromised patient
in the first two days of copying native
vaccine
as i just showed you
and in parallel uh
naturally in far left of our work uh
other team have uh
working on the same
of the same on similar studies
and these studies were gradually
available
from march to now
our colleague from strasbourg in france
have rapidly
showed that in a short report
the published the result of
the efficiency of the first dose
of vaccination of committed
vaccination in kidney transplant
friendship recipient
the observe the response
in 250
serial negative kinetic transformations
and
show that as you can see in
the figure
a lot of patients stay
seronegative and
the level of resistance is
very very different from a patient to
another
the difference with house 2d is the
vaccine used
it was modern and
the show that two
characteristics are
significantly associated with lower
response
it is the time from kidney
transportation
more you are an old kidney transplant
recipient
uh all the that that is the time
between like the
transportation and the vaccination
more the response is low and
another characteristic is very important
is
the immunosuppressive regimen used
and uh we
find again in this study
the role of immunosuppressive regimen
in the
low level of response are already
published for
all the vaccine in
2011.
the same the same team continue to
follow
the patients and the
analyze the response after seven days
and after the first dose there was
around ten percent
of response and after the second dose
immunization rates reached
for 48 percent
48 48
they analyze at the same time the impact
of
different immunosuppressive regiment and
mycophenolate morphisil seems to be
very implied in
the
[Music]
low response the steroid again
also and uh tachoremus
is responsible also from
lower response than cyclosporine
or low calcium urine inhibitors
so there is a real impact of
immunosuppressive
regimen
concerning laboratory stations there was
a study published
recently that show
the response is
very vary from a patient from another
but 93 persons
of patients have a response for second
dose
it is very different from
kidney transformation and that's why
the recommendation
vaccination is different between both
groups
but the level of substance is very
different
between patients and we
note also that there is a decrease
as shown in the last figure
right there is a decrease
of the level of response
with the edge
concerning our study we recruited
emo dialysis patients
78 74 kidney transplant recipients
and seven controls
naturally the local research committee
gave its authorization
for the study and french commission for
that privacy
give an authorization number for the
city
the control group was constituted by
member of the medical staff
vaccinated between february and march
2021
and included in the institutional
post-vaccine follow-up program
of the universe service hospital of
remote
sometiming the backside news
all the patients were all the patients
and controls were vaccinated
with the community community
community from fizer
different reasons for this choice
uh it was the first faction approved by
french health authorities
and uh
that is validated for uh such
vaccinations
in comprised patient the
skill was two doses
of 30 microgram 20
28 days apart
his backside
is composed of rna
as you know enveloped with
lipidic nanoparticles that allow to
enter the cells and
lower the then the production from the
mrna
of the spike protein
the antibodies developed after
introduction and stimulation of human
response
on naturally fantasy antibodies
with
rpd
the efficacy essentially in
immunocompetent patients
was was proved with
a decrease of excretion and
decrease of duration
of severe forms
concerning the workflow of the cd the
blood samples were connected from
d0 to d58
then there is screening of infected
patients
to exclude to exclude them from the
study
then we evaluate the zero convention the
zero conversion
post vaccination we
try to determine antibody specificity
with a new
test and then we
begin to perform neutralization essays
the different methods of the study used
were
the alinity sasquatch ii igg
assay from about to detect antibodies
by chemiluminescence uh
uh against the protein n
the three cells of the say one 1.4
then we used the uh
saskatoon igg trimeric
from diatherin on the
lysine analyzer
to perform the evaluation of the servo
conversion
this result of vsa was
see and uh three
and the range of the essay was from
one point eighty five to
eight hundred after 800 you can
delete the serum to obtain
the real studies and
as i presided just before
we used a new test
completely manual test uh
based on i idiot technology
by colorimetry to
analyze the specificity of antigen
because this assay is a load
flows to detect the response against
n protein the response
again subunit of s protein s1 is to
endamine abdomen and receptor by the
domain uh
some word about this test
which is very nice
and allowed to
[Music]
come bring some additional information
but it is
not automatic automatically
so it's very long to practice
and
not adapt it to large
screening
strategy but for our say
we it
you will see that it had it has
some very interesting information
so the result is are very easy to read
because
uh if you uh read
m that's uh
it corresponds to on the end please
if you read the s it corresponds to s1
on cs1 antibodies if
you have the ntd
detection detection is corresponding to
on the ltd
and in blue here you have the
localization of anti rbd
domain and in black here in the left
you are the anti-s2 antibodies
our strategy to determine patient zero
status was
on the first error serum at this arrow
to screen with
the harvard test against
and protein all the positive results
were considered as 90 infected prior to
vaccination so excluded from the gd
in order to compare only people naive
from contact with kobe did
all negative screen samples
were included in the study group of
pakistani energy cct
and tested with the lysosome subscribe
to trimeric's
igg test
concerning the profile of patient uh
described here
all the data will be soon available in
the publication in the journal of
american association of
nephrology the paper is accepted
two weeks ago so
[Music]
just the some points
concerning the age of the population
you can see that our control group was
younger is around
50 years old
comparison we immortalize this patient
or
kidney transport recipient the sex ratio
was similar
in each group
concerning the different
[Music]
pathology
that are responsible for dialysis or
in the transportation there is no big
difference between both groups
and we
to to evaluate the
uh linear response
against after vaccination we
use another parameter because all these
patients
are vaccinated against
hepatitis b virus and
we analyze the responses against this
bias
the organization
we analyze also aluminium level limit
discount
and naturally the immunosuppressive
regimen has
was already described in literature
that the supressive regimen could have
an important impact and
for hemodialysis patients we
examine also the ptv ratio
to determine if there is a link
with the response
containing the zero commerce stereo
conversion rates
here you can find the final results
published but we
continue the analyze over time
to follow up our patients
you can see the very important
difference
and a very low zero conversion rate
in uh kidney transplant recipient
only 10 at the
58. so uh
in contrary the emo dialysis patient
responds like in the other public
application of that i showed before
with around
90 of response and
the controls have all
seven all seven controls
have a hundred percent
of serotonin several comparisons
at two weeks after after the first house
so the difference is
very marked between this group
and it is
represented in the figure
the right of the slide
where you can see in parallel
of the operation the operation of
antibodies you can see the different
level
of antibodies with a large
large dispersion of value
in hemodialysis patients
even in
people that respond to the backside
and the better the
better response in the controls
[Music]
to look at the antibody tutors
more precisely uh you are the first
doors
at the zeros even though that
a week after so um
the level
of antibody
is very different between groups and
you have to be careful
uh for the level of
kidney transplant precision because two
patients
are other
very high level of antibodies
so and you can see the
sigma test due to
to explain that uh
the mean that's very good
he's not representative from uh
from the level of response of kidney
transplant
recipients
when we examined
the courage the hb
vaccine response in immodialysis
patients
we find a very good correlation
between teters of
anti-task of two antibodies and
twitters of anti-hbs
antibody
the difference uh are very significant
between special in the patient
between the patients who are
who are negative who have sorry
a negative response uh
after hepatitis b vaccination
and versus intermediary response
and it is also significant between
negative
and high teachers
we find we found other factors
associated with response
in hemodialysis patients there was no
relation between the diabetes
gender bmi and agility prediction
however we observed high term cbody
production in patient age under
70a 75 years
compared to those age over
78. suggesting that antibody response
was
associated with age
in addition serum beaming and
kt v ratio were also
positively correlated with theoretical
risk respectively
to better understand the response
uh in such patients we try to
determine the specificity of antibodies
that's to say
against which on gem
of the spy protein the antibodies
are directed
so we
until now we have only tested
55 sample
all other experimentation
are ongoing and
the test
we wanted to
examine to look at the
results between
1.85
and 13.
between these results are considered
as negative with the idg tremendous
s test but when we
look at the follow-up of the patients
all the patients with such teeters
developed a better response
in the following samples
so that's why we have
40 patients in this group
and only three patients in the
group inferior to one point
85 and
12 patients on the other group posing
uh
so we can note that there is a very good
specificity
because when the igg turmeric test
is under 1.8
5 there is no response detected
in the kovi jag say concerning the
positive test
with igg two were negative with kobe jag
but it was
results close to those results around
just around those results and
they were positive on the next sample so
it could be also
a
limit of the cabinet test in
sensitivity uh
what we observe with this test is that
there is polyclonal antibody response
in vaccines that is robust
and among
32 positives
we detected
15 patients with
15 samples with a polycarbonate antibody
response
and among uh
10 of them were have
idiot numeric results over
here it's an example of the kinetic of
antibody and you can see
depending on the day after vaccination
the operation
i'm sorry it's a little small but you
can see the operation of antibodies
on the different well
of the test emoji
at the top it is the kinetic
of the hemodialysis patient and
in the bottom you can see the control uh
scale worker where the operation
of antibodies is begins
at two weeks after vaccination
after this test we wanted to know
if our
serum of our patient could naturalize
virus so we developed
an essay in how uh nsb3
laboratory in the teaching university
hospital of immersion where we collected
[Music]
positive sample from patients we
uh we have uh bywords
we developed by our culture of
covalent in and then we
test the
serum of our vaccinated patients
that we incubate with
one particle one however
and then we inoculate the
sample in error cells
microplates and incubate them
between five and seven days
and then we check the if there is
a systematic effect in the culture
until now we only analyze six serum
two from the controller group two from a
model registration and two from
uh kidney transport free shipping
all developed
[Music]
all of the the serum tested
neutralized virus
in cell culture so it's very interesting
but all these results should be
confirmed
on the other sample
in the literature recently i
find paper that showed the there is uh
after vaccination an injection of
functionality
diverse antibodies
against rbd nuclear terminal domain
and as the part of the protein
so it's interesting that
it is
is that it is
similar with our results
but in this publication
the show saw that
the vaccination induced a high rate of
non-natural lining
antibody so we will continue our
tests in our lab laboratories to
dilute our
our different theorem and
determine the title of natural
neutralization
of each sample of the patient
to summarize the different results of
our study we can
observe that there is a weak rate of
zero conversion
in the transform recipient
is there is a bias of patient selection
but our our patients
are often
under mycophenol atmosphere
immunosuppressive regimen
perhaps more people than in other cities
that could be that could explain that
our cell
conversion rate in our city is lower
uh is there is a link to pakistan news
the
study of our colleagues from strasbourg
used modern american
we use physiology perhaps the response
could be could have some difference
our patients are older than in other
studies
we note although
a good response in immortal disease
patients
like other studies
and what is very interesting is that
the response to each bp vaccine
could be predictive from response to
covet 90 vaccine
we have to continue the follow-up to
determine the persistence
of antibody over the time and
to use a different test
of specificity of the different
sample and the materialization capacity
concerning the perspective of our
such population concerning
the vaccination the
probably the vaccination strategy
could be adapted to the population type
with perhaps a choice of vaccines
different
depending from the population the number
of those that
should be administrated is
will be different depending from
the population type and the interest
of igd-antis dosage for
a large number of immunocompressors even
compromised patients
some take home message to end my
presentation
uh so the kidney transform patient have
not the same rate of several convention
after vaccination than llc people
and it's the same for probably all the
uh
transplants which you can respond could
depend on the backside injected response
profile could be similar for
blood vaccination so it could be
indication
to observe past response
to the vaccine and theology testing with
auntie's detection essay is essential to
manage a follow-up
of immunocompromised people
i want to acknowledge uh the nephrology
team
of our hospital the biology team
and particularly my technicians of the
unit
and mrs vessage of dietary
for providing the
creaminess assay for the test
thank you for your attention
thank you professor hunts for your
informative presentation
we will now start the q a portion of the
webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located
on the far left of your screen and we'll
answer as many questions as we have time
for
okay let's go ahead and get started our
first question
is what are the benefits that you have
seen using turmeric s igg assay
um before the
premier x essay was available
we have already used the first say of
diazering company
allowing the detection of igg
against is one s2 part of the spike
um on contrary towards
detecting the agg against n-protein
proposed until despair at this time
by a lot of companies a say of diathermy
allowed to check the humeral resistance
after vaccination
and have at the same time the ability to
detect
naturally combine 19 past infection
that's why that's why we use this test
in our laboratory
in our laboratory at the beginning of
the pandemics
now such tests are very relevant
relevant for the detection
of antibodies in vaccinated patients
it's another step of in the pandemic
and the strategy could be
coupled both tests
with antenna detection in a diagnostic
lab
and on cs in parallel in order to
differentiate
post-infection from vaccination
after this evaluation of frameworks xsa
we can't say in our experience that
it's very easy to use essay on the
efficient
liaison excel analyzer
which can contain many tests on board
the comparison within the kobi diag
essay
manual test that i showed in my
presentation showed that
it is able to detect a large panel of
antibody
amongst the antigen of the
criminal x14 directed against
the essential antigen of the spike the
rbd
and terminal domain s1 and h2 so
it brings new information
uh than the
s100 raised to sa it's
it's a real good evolution from the
first test
and
i want to add a precision concerning the
result
our results were obtained with the first
batch of the regent
not correlated with the wa2
who internal
control international control so the
current batch are now available
and designed to give results
correlated to this who
international control so uh
for people we who could use
the new patch uh they will not be
surprised
that the three thousand of positive
results is different from
them that i gave in my presentation
concerning the neutralization essay
the first results that we have are very
enthusiastic because all three patients
have
neutralizing utilities and the test
in the information gave given by
uh diathermy the test
seems to be well correlated with the
trial neutralizing
essay so we want to continue to to check
this point and especially in our
population probably
where the development of
human response is more difficult
so i think it's
a good test and that
could bring a lot of information
in the post vaccination
okay thank you all right your next
question
what are the recommendations for the
vaccine
program in the population of fragile
individuals
given the risk of civil disease and the
height
mortality uh compared to the general
population
the french health authorities and the
society of
the french society of transportation or
the french society of
nephrology dialysis transformative and
transplantation
recommended vaccination of all
previously
transported patients and if possible
with immunological monitoring
so it's very uh important to precise
this point
uh when patients are recent transplants
it would be advisable to vacuum it with
it at least
one month and three to six months for
patients
who have received t or b cell debating
agents
and because we have
we saw that the impact of
immunosuppressive regimen
is very important in the response
after vaccination if possible for
patient
awaiting transportation it is
recommended
that you vaccinate
with the same strategy
but before transplantation that you need
to be
protected at the time of transportation
in this case in these cases the response
will be better naturally because
the patient has not
patients these patients have not given a
suppressive recipient because before
transportation
and there could be a beneficiate
for the humeral
protection just
before the graft
[Music]
and for transformation from living
relative dinner
it is also also recommended that the
donor
should be vaccinated
as i showed uh concurrent results of
different teams in france
and also around the world
were observed and
so obsessory that a low response
in kidney transplant resistance and more
widely
probably in all immunocompromised
people this
observation drove the franchise
authority to decide that
a third dose is required is required
for all solid organ transplantation for
all hematopoietic stem cell transplant
patients we are treated with strong
immunosuppression
on tcd-20 and the precise
for some hemodialysis patients
after medical advice and
if i look at our results
we can note that 10
of hemodialysis patients didn't respond
and probably for such patients
for those is necessary
and could allow to obtain
a response
[Music]
the second the dispersals should be
administrated one month after the second
and we can add
that for vaccine recommendation
it's essential to vaccinate the family
circle
and people which deals with
immunocompromised
immunocompromised patients
thank you professor hans looks like we
have time for one last question today
the question is how do you see the
future for
serology testing for copen19 in a
setting of
fragile individuals
um
it is a reality that after the
introduction
of that since the tradition of the
vaccination
uh it's essential now
to have in a diagnosis laboratory
probably different to say for
covenanting
theory probably
as we used in house 2d
a test that allows the detection of on
tn
itg because
it's important to
to discriminate people
vaccinated from people infected
and the and
essentially for people
who have been vaccinated
who have not a good response
and then would develop
probably who could develop
symptoms of koban koval
kovid 90. so it's important for the
discrimination to
have probably such tests but
now it is essential to
have a test
that load to detect on ts igg
to assess the immune response post
vaccination
and for this test the performance are
critical
because you should be naturally positive
but specificity is more important in
this case
in order not to consider a patient
unvaccinated
if its response is not
concerning the quantification it's an
important point
uh to
allow to determine
the characteristic
of the result of the patient response
and to follow
this response over time
we observe different response in
current studies that could also depend
on the theorgy test used
because antigen are different
in the test and correlation with
who international control not available
for all tests so these points are also
important and finally
the tests should be well correlated with
the detection of neutralizing antibody
because it's these antibodies that
are crucial for the protection
of for the fight against the virus
so to summarize uh it's essential to
follow the
humoral response what vaccination is
fragile patient
with well validated tests in order to
know
if your patients are protected
if you need another dose for example for
to have the example of a hemodialysis
patient
patient under weak immunosuppressive
therapy
we have often the question from
clinician or from
from patients that want to know
if a patient we
created with with a weak
immunosuppressive therapy have responded
to to the backside
and in such cases the level of response
should be a criteria to decide to
re-vaccinate
or not
thank you professor hunts for your time
today we would also like to thank
labruz and our sponsor diathorin for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we do not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by our speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye